الله
اكبر
اشهد ان اله الا الله
اشهد ان لا
اله الا الله
اشهد ان محمدا رسول الله
[Arabic recitation]
اكبر الله
اكبر
لا
اله الا الله
[Silence]
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم ان الحمد لله
نحمده ونستعينه ونستغفره
ونعوذ بالله من شرور انفسنا وسيئات
اعمالنا
من يهده الله فلا مضل له
ومن يضلل فلا هادي له
واشهد ان لا اله الا الله وحده لا شريك له
واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله
يا ايها الذين امنوا اتقوا الله حق تقاته
ولا تموتن الا وانتم مسلمون
يا ايها الناس اتقوا ربكم الذي خلقكم من
نفس واحده
وخلق منها زوجها
وبث منهما رجالا كثيرا ونساء
واتقوا الله الذي تساءلون
به والارحام
ان الله كان عليكم رقيبا
يا ايها الذين امنوا اتقوا الله وقولوا
قولا سديدا
يصلح لكم اعمالكم
ويغفر لكم ذنوبكم
ومن يطع الله ورسوله فقد فاز فوزا عظيما.
اما بعد فان اصدق الحديث كتاب الله
وخير الهدي هدي محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم
وشر الامور محدثاتها
وكل محدثه بدعه
وكل بدعه ضلاله
وكل ضلاله في النار
اما بعد
فقد اخرج الامام مسلم في صحيحه باسناده عن
عبد الله بن عمر بن الخطاب
رضي الله عنه وعن ابيه
قال
رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
لا يموتن احدكم الا وهو يحسن الظن بالله
عز وجل
وقال ذلك قبل وفاته بثلاث
الحافظ الامام مسلم
صلى الله عليه وسلم
days
‏Let none of you die
unless he is
making good
unate
unى
حسن الظن
وسوء الظن
الله
الله سبحانه وتالى
صلى الله عليه وسلم
un
الله عز وجل
was
عليه الصلاه والسلام
life days
ابن عمر
صحيح مسلم
صلى الله عليه وسلم
الله
انا عند ظن عبدي
وزاد ابو داوود السجستاني في سننه
انا عند ظن عبدي ب فان ظن خيرا فله
وان ظن شرا فله
صلى
الله
[Silence]
‏What did our prop was
you
life
un thinking best ofscribing
him the best ofption
best ofates
الله سبحانه وتعالى
ولا تموتن الا وانتم مسلمون
اللهم
‏lives
and tells us do not diecept in
it means your every waking moment in the
state of isl
so that you may die upon that
and tells
‏in all in all
in times of good and in times of bad in
times of ease and in times of difficulty
always maintain that best of estimates
of
the propetall عليه وسلم
الحمد لله
الذي بنعمته تتم الصالحات
الحمد لله على كل حال
[Silence]
سبحانه وتعالى
الحمد لله على كل حال
الله
[Silence]
سبحانه وتعالى
مالك الموط
الموضى الامام مالك سن ابي داوود انس رضي
الله عنهصار
يقول مرض
رجل من الانصار
فكان على فراش الموت
فاتاه رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم يعوده
فقال كيف انت يا فلان
فقال بخير يا رسول الله
ارجو الله واخاف ذنوبي
لاحظوا
الظن والاعتقاد
ولاحظوا هاتين الخصلتين اللتين اجتمعتا في
قلب هذا الرجل يقول
ارجو الله
واخاف ذنوبي
فقال له رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
مجيبا
لا يجتمعان
في قلب عبد في مثل هذا الموطن
الا اتاه الله ما يرجو
وامنه مما يخاف
هذا هو الظن بالله عز وجل
ان يظن الخير وان يرجو الله سبحانه وتعالى
ويخاف ذنب نفسه
هذا هو حسن الظن
نسبه الخير
وكل الخير الى الله
ونسبه الشر الى النفس
يقول
ربنا سبحانه وتعالى حكايه عن الجن
تعلموا مما سمعوه من كتاب الله
لما استمعوا واستمع نفر من الجن
قالوا
وانا لا ندري اشر اريد يد بمن في الارض ام
اراد بهم ربهم رشدا
نسبوا الخير الى الله
ولم ينسبوا الشر الى الله سبحانه وتعالى
بل ذكروا الشر هنا
بصيغه
ما لم يذكر فاعله كما يقول النحاه
وانا لا ندري
اشر اريد ما قالوا اشر اراد الله او اشرا
اراد الله قالوا اشر اريد بمن في الارض ام
اراد بهم ربهم رشدا هذا هو حسن الظن بالله
عز وجل
انصار
صلى الله عليه وسلم
wasله
him
يا فلان
بخير
well
in الله and my sin
here I hing in Allah
I fear my own sin
and so the propet
responded
الله
anycept
[Silence]
‏estimate الله سبحانه وتالى
حسن الظن
الله
[Silence]
ابو هريره
صلى الله عليه وسلم
الامام مسلم
قال
اذنب عبد ذنبا
فقال اي ربي يعني يا ربي اذنبت ذنبا فاغفر
لي فقال الله
علم عبدي ان له ربا يغفر الذنب وياخذ
بالذنب
غفرت له
ثم عاد فاذنب
فقال اي ربي اني قد اذنبت فاغفر لي فقال
الله
ان عبدي اذنب ذنبا فعلم ان له ربا يغفر
الذنب وياخذ بالذنب
فغفر الله له ثم عاد فاذنب فقال اي ربي قد
اذنبت ذنبا فاغفر لي فقال الله
ان عبدي اذنب ذنبا فعلم ان له ربا يغفر
الذنب وياخذ بالذنب
قد غفرت لعبدي فليفعل ما شاء
يعني فليفعل ما شاء
فان الله يتوب عليه وما دام يجتمع هذا
الظن بالله عز وجل حين التوبه
يعلم ان له ربا يغفر الذنب وياخذ بالذنب
وان الله سبحانه وتعالى قد يعاقب العبد
وله كل حق ان يعاقب العبد كيف شاء ومتى
شاء لكنه يرجو رحمه الله ويخاف عذابه
فقال الله
قد غفرت لعبد فليفعل ما شاء وهذا يدل على
ان الخير لابد وان يدمغ الشر ولو بعد حين
فانه يذنب هذا هو الشر ثم يستغفر وقلبه
مليء بهذا الظن
فهنا الذنب وال والاستغفار والتوبه
في صراع فما دام يتوب فلا بد ان تصرع
التوبه الذنب لابد
بل نقذف بالحق على الباطل فيدمغه فاذا هو
زاهق
لابد
ان يغلب الخير ولو بعد حين
مسلم ابو هريره
صلى الله عليه وسلم
comm
someম
‏My
pleas
and
my
sin
hecknowledges
that he has a lord who isable of
forgiving and rightful forisal
he is capable of forgiving and he is
also capable of punishing
I forgive my servant
‏was
not
want
الله
consci
‏so that he can enjoy himself
momentarily in the fleeting moments of
disobedience
but true
good just estimate of Allah is that a
person
seek forgiveness for his sin and his
heart is filled with hope and fear that
is what get sins forgiven
he says the man then
‏and to my sin again pleas for me and
tells us what going on in this man heart
when
the words for me he says Allah responded
and said my servant
acknledes
even though he has sinned that he has a
lord who is capable of forgiveness
‏and again to my sin again
for me
and responded
my slave has sin he has disobeed me yet
he believes and acknowledges that he has
a lord
‏able
of judg of punishment
I have for my slave let him do as he
pleases this doesn't mean that he can
now go and sin all he want that is not
what is me what is me by the
for is to do as he choes meaning when a
person
الله سبحانه وتعالى
الله
‏because
of him
not
forgiving as well that belief with the
knowledge that Allah can has and will
punish
those whom he chooses fit
[Silence]
فاما الرغد فيذهب جفاءه واما ما ينفع
الناس فيمكث في
‏hand
even ifarily
to have permeated
will always previlent
and will always
and we see here that two sides of this
opposition
we have the
‏have
and asent
the sin will be for will go awayent
because true forgiveness from
gu
a person will just keep sinning forever
no true
يقول الله تعالى سواء عليهم استغفرت لهم
ام لم تستغفر لهم لن يغفر الله لهم
ان الله لا يهدي القوم الفاسقين
اذا
مغفره الله
تشاهد في ارضه بالهدايه
من غفر الله له يهديه في مستقبله
ولكن هؤلاء المنافقين
سواء عليهم استغفر لهم رسول الله ام لم
يستغفر لهم لن يغفر الله لهم اي في الاخره
وفي الدنيا لن يهديهم
سيتمادون في نفاقهم الى يوم ان يلقوا ربهم
والعياذ
‏And so this is trs of
when understands that is forgiving
اللهish to
when a person understands that Allah
does not desire to punish someone who is
repentant
but he has and will punish if a person
takes his mercy for granted
اقول ما تسمعون واستغفر الله لي ولكم
ولسائر المسلمين فاستغفروه
انه هو الغفور الرحيم
[Arabic recitation]
واشهد ان لا اله الا الله وحده لا شريك له
واشهد ان محمدا عبده
ورسوله اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا
محمد وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين اما بعد
[Silence]
‏trust him with this watch and he say
look fix this for me correct it I'll be
back to pick it up
so the customer leaves
and the people around the watchmaker
they say wow this customer is a true
catch
this customer is extremely generous
everyone wants to deal with him because
he gives very good tips and he pays
beyond
‏is
theer
he understands that this is a generous
man so he takes his and he breaks it
into a000 pieces and then wait for his
customer to come back and pay him is
this what we would call good thoughts of
his customer a just estimate he's
generous
being that he's generous I can do
whatever I
[Silence]
ولله المثل الاعلى
الله سبحانه وتعالى
‏take life and fl to
me iarn anything iud anything i was toy
i was what i want to do where i do how i
do it me and i and me and i and me and
‏meryate
الله سبحانه وتالى
make
the
person
if thoughts are
forgiving andelying on
يوسف وتكون من بعده قوما صالحين يوسف
things are
all
wor
‏mery commied
الله
people
of nonlult
‏when it has to do with things I did
this I thism
I I ch is popped out but then something
bad happens why would a god this to
happen why is it that only bad things
arecribed to god and good things are to
me and this and
if gods
people
الله
ما اصابك من حسنه فمن الله وما اصابك من
سيئه فمن نفسك
نسال الله سبحانه وتعالى بمنه وكرمه وجوده
ان يغفر لنا خطايانا وان يتوب علينا وان
يعفو عنا اللهم اغفر لنا ذنوبنا وكفر عنا
سيئاتنا وتوفنا مع الابرار ربنا واتنا ما
وعدتنا على رسلك ولا تخزنا يوم القيامه
انك لا تخلف الميعاد اللهم اننا نعوذ بك
من درك الشقاء وسوء القضاء وشماته الاعداء
اللهم اننا نسالك عيش السعداء ومنازل
الشهداء ومنازل الشهداء ومنازل الشهداء
والنصر على الاعداء ومرافقه الانبياء يا
سميع الدعاء يا ذا المن والعطاء اللهم
اننا نعوذ بك من الزنا والغلى والربا
والزلاز والزلازل والفتن اللهم اننا نسالك
فعل الخيرات وترك المنكرات وحب المساكين
وان تغفر لنا وترحمنا وتتوب علينا واذا
اردت بعبادك فتنه فاقبضنا اليك غير
مفتونين اللهم انصر اخواننا المجاهدين في
كل مكان وفي غزه وفلسطين وفي لبنان ان وفي
سوريا وفي السودان وحيث حلوا يا رب
العالمين ووقفوا موقف ارغام لاعدائك اللهم
انصرهم نصرا مؤزرا اللهم انصرهم نصرا
مؤزرا اللهم عليك بهذا الكيان الصهيون
اللعين فانه قد عاث في الارض فسادا اللهم
دمره تدميرا اللهم زلزل اركانه
اللهم صدع بنيانه اللهم
اللهم
فزع
رب العالمين
يا ربعل
احقتلا
يتقلب
الله
الجنا
وعلىعين